ALBERT MEYER: Today's
topic is random variables.
Random variables are an
absolutely fundamental concept
in probability theory.
But before we get into
officially defining them,
let's start off
with an example that
in fact, is a game because
that's a fun way to start.
So we're going to play
the bigger number game
and here's how it works.
There are two teams,
and Team 1 has
the task of picking two
different integers between 0
and 7 inclusive, and
they write one integer
on one piece of paper
and the other integer
on the other piece of paper.
They turn the two
pieces of paper
face down so the
numbers are not visible,
and the other team then sees
these two pieces of paper
whose other side has
different numbers written
on them sitting on the table.
What Team 2 then does is picks
one of the pieces of paper
and turns it over and
looks at the number on it.
And then, based on
what that number
is, they make a decision,
stick with the number
they have or switch to the
other unknown number on the face
down piece of paper.
And that'll be
their final number.
And the game is that Team
2 wins if they wind up
with the larger number.
So they're going to look
at the number on the paper
that they expose
and they're going
to try to decide
whether it looks
like a big number
or little number.
If it looks like a big
number, they'll stick with it.
If it looks like
a little number,
they'll switch to the other
one that they hope is larger.
So which team do you think
has an advantage here?
Course, if you've read
the notes, you know.
But if you haven't been
exposed to this before,
it's not really so obvious.
And what we
encourage and what we
used to do when we ran this
in real time in classes
that we would have
students in teams, split
their team in half,
one would be Team 1
and the other would
be Team 2, and they'd
play the game few times,
see if they could figure out
who had the advantage.
And if you have the
opportunity, this
might be a good moment
to stop this video
and try playing the game with
some friends if they're around.
Otherwise, let's just proceed
and see how it all works.
So this is the strategy
Team 2 is going to adopt.
They're going to take this
idea about big and small
that I mentioned and act
on it in a methodical way.
So they're going to pick
a paper to expose, giving
each paper equal probability.
So that guarantees
that they have
a 50/50 chance of picking the
big number and a 50/50 chance
of picking the little number.
Whatever ingenuity Team 1 tried
to do on which piece of paper
was on the left and
which was on the right,
it doesn't really matter if Team
2 simply picks a piece of paper
at random.
There's no way
that Team 1 can try
to fake out Team 2 on
where they put the number.
OK.
The next step is
that Team 2 is going
to decide whether the
number that they can see,
the exposed number, is small.
And if so, would they switch?
And otherwise they stick.
So that is, they're going to
define some threshold Z where
being less than or
equal to Z means small,
and being greater
than Z means large.
The question is, how
do they choose Z?
Well, a naive thing
to do would be
to choose Z to be in the middle
of the interval from 0 to 7.
Let's say, you
choose Z equals 3.
So there would be four numbers
less than or equal to Z
and four numbers greater
than Z. But of course,
as soon as Team 1 knew that that
was your Z, what would they do?
Well, they would make sure
that both numbers were
on the same side of
Z. If you're Z was 3,
they would always choose their
numbers to be, say, 0 and 1.
And that way, when
you were switching,
your Z would tell you that
you had a small number,
you should switch
to the other one.
And you'd only have a
50/50 chance of winning.
So if you fixed that
value of Z, Team 2
has a way of ensuring that
you have no advantage.
You can only win with
probability 50/50.
And that's true no
matter what Z you take.
If Team 1 knew what
your Z was, they
would just make sure
to pick their two
numbers on the same
side of your Z.
And then your Z wouldn't
really tell you anything.
You'd switch or
stick in both cases,
and you'd only
have a 50/50 chance
of picking the right number.
So what you do-- and this is
where probability comes in--
is you pick Z in a way that
can't be predicted or made
use of by Team 1.
You pick Z at random, to
be any number from 0 to 7,
not including 7 including 0.
That is, your number is
either 0, 1, 2, up through 6.
And being less than or
equal to Z means small,
and being greater
than Z means large.
And when you see a small
number, you'll switch
and when you see a large
number, you'll stick.
But what's going to be large
and what's going to be small
is going to vary each time
you play the game, depending
on what random number,
Z, comes out to be.
So let's analyze your
probability if you're Team 2.
What's the probability that
you're going to win now?
Well, let's suppose that Team
1 picks these two numbers.
We don't know what
they are, but they
have to pick a low number
that's less than a high number.
So these two numbers
are at least 1 apart,
they can't have the same
number on both pieces of paper.
Otherwise, it's clear
that you are not
going to be able to
pick the large one, that
would be cheating.
OK, so there's two
different numbers.
So one of them has to
be less than the other.
We don't know how much
less, might be a lot less,
might be only one less,
but low is less than high.
OK, now we can consider
three cases of what
happens with your strategy.
The most interesting
case is the middle case.
That is, when your Z,
which was chosen at random,
happens to fall in the
interval between low and high.
That is, your Z is strictly
less than high and greater than
or equal to low.
And then in that case, your Z
is really guiding you correctly
on what to do.
If you turn over the
low card, then it's
going to look low because
it's less than or equal to Z
so you'll switch to
the high card and win.
If you turn over
the high card, it's
going to be greater than
Z so it'll look high
and you'll know
to stick with it.
So in this case, you're
guaranteed to win.
If you were lucky
enough to guess
the right threshold between low
and high, you're going to win.
And so the probability
that you win,
given the middle
case occurs, is 1.
Now, what about the middle case?
How often does that happen?
Well, the difference between
low and high is at least 1,
so there's guaranteed
to be 1 chance in 7
that your Z is going
to fall between them.
And it could be more if low
and high are further apart,
but as long as they're
at least one apart,
there's a 1/7 chance that you're
going to fall in between them.
OK.
Now, in case H,
that's the case where
Z happens to be
chosen greater than
or equal to the high
number that Team 1 shows.
In other words, Z is bigger
than both numbers than Team 1
shows and put on
the pieces of paper.
Well, in that case, Z just
isn't telling you anything.
So what's going to happen is
that both numbers are going
to look high to you--
sorry-- both numbers
are going to look low to you
because they're both less than
or equal to Z. So you'll switch.
And that means that
you'll win, if and only
if, you happen to turn
the low card over first.
Well that was 50/50.
So the probability
that you win, given
that Z-- both cards are
on the low side of Z,
you'll win with half the time.
And symmetrically, if Z is
less than the low card, that
is, Z is less than both
cards chosen by Team 1,
then they're both going to
look high, and so you'll stick.
And that means that you'll
stick, you'll win, if and only
if, you happen to have
picked the high card.
There's a 50/50 chance of that.
So again, in this case that
Z makes both cards look high,
or Z itself is low, Team 2,
you win with probability 1/2.
Well, that's great because now
we can apply total probability.
And what total probability
tells us is that Team 2 wins
is the probability that
they win given case
M times the probability
of M plus the probability
that they win given
not the middle case
times the probability
of not the middle case.
But we figured out
what these were.
Well, at least
inequalities on them,
because there's
probability 1 that you'll
win 1/7 of the time.
And there's probability
a 1/2 that you'll
win the rest of the time,
the other 6/7 of the time.
You're going to win
4/7 of the time.
The probability that you win
playing your strategy is 4/7.
It's better than 50/50.
You have an advantage.
And whether that was a priori
obvious or not, I don't know.
But I think it's kind of cool.
OK, you win with
probability 4/7.
Now, Team 2 has the advantage.
And the important
thing to understand
is it does not matter
what team does.
No matter how smart
Team 1 is, Team 2
has gotten control
of the situation
because they picked--
which piece of paper
they picked at random 50/50.
So it doesn't matter
what strategy Team 1 used
on where they
placed the numbers.
And they chose Z
randomly, so again, it
doesn't matter what
numbers Team 1 shows.
Team 2 is still going to have
their 1/7 chance of coming out
ahead, which is enough to tip
the balance in their favor.
It's interesting that
symmetrically, Team 1 also
has a random strategy
that they can use,
which guarantees that no
matter what Team 2 does, Team 2
wins with probability
at most 4/7.
So either team can
force the probability
that Team 2 wins to be at
most 4/7 and at least 4/7.
So if they both play optimally,
it's going to stay at 4/7.
And that's again, true no
matter what Team 2 does,
Team 1 can put this
upper bound to 4/7 on it.
So essentially we can
say that the value
of this game, the
probability that Team 2 wins
is optimally for both is 4/7.
OK, now what does this game
got to do with anything,
with our general topic
of random variables?
Well, we'll be
formal in a moment.
But informally,
a random variable
is simply a number that's
produced by a random process.
And just to give an
example before we come up
with a formal definition,
the threshold variable Z
was a thing that took a
value from 0 to 6 inclusive,
each with probability 1/7.
So it was producing a
number by a random process,
that chose a number at random
with equal probability.
If Team 2 plays properly
at random picking which
piece of paper to expose, then
the number of the exposed card,
or more precisely, whether the
exposed card is high or low,
will also be a random variable.
And if Team 1 plays optimally,
the number on the exposed card
is going to be a
random variable.
That is, Team 1 in their
optimal strategy that
puts an upper bound to 4/7 is
in fact, going to choose the two
numbers randomly.
So the exposed card
is going to wind up
being another random
variable, a number produced
by the random process.
And likewise, the number
of the larger card
if Team 1 picks its larger
and smaller cards randomly,
it's going to be another
example of a number produced
by a random process.
And likewise, the number
of the smaller card.
So that's enough examples.
This little game
has a whole bunch
of random variables
appearing in it.
And in the next
segment, we will look
again officially,
what is the definition
of a random variable?